versus brexit position in the words of
the shadow chancellor has evolved a
pretty generous assessment of what looks
like a pretty seismic shift in policy
but the party is already under pressure
to go further with a letter in today's
observer from more than 80 senior party
figures including 37 in piece demanding
that Labour commit to the single market
as well as a customs union after Beck
said that is something we will of course
be discussing with Labour's shadow 20
general Baroness Chakrabarty who joins
me now lovely to see you again very good
morning and but we start first with your
visit to Yuans woods you know clearly
the people inside there are desperate to
get out you and the shadow home
secretary of being desperate for almost
a year now to get inside what did you
discover it was more than a year
actually and I think that's that's the
first point to make in in a democracy
should it take nearly 18 months for the
shadow home secretary to be allowed to
visit these people who feel desperate
who feel forgotten and it's no surprise
that people who are held indefinitely so
they don't know when they're going to be
released are going to be desperate that
that is the policy if that's an inhumane
policy that we want to end in government
but I was also concerned about aspects
of of the regime inside inside the
centre there are a number of women who
say they've been on hunger strike
yet the managers of surco the private
company that runs the establishment
flatly deny that I heard there was a
pretty heated discussion with it with a
GP well I'm not the other staying there
there were women expressing concerns
about their health care saying that
before they were detained they had
access to to various medication or they
were pending operations on the outside
that all evaporates when they come in
they're told some of them that they are
being drama queens or offered a
paracetamol when we tried to very
politely I promise you express this to
the the duty doctor the young doctor
employed by g4s a different private
company profiting from this human misery
he was it was really incredibly
defensive and angry that we should even
be coming in to the establishment and
that really surprised me because I would
expect
doctors to be doctors first and and
company employees second I suppose the
question is because there is there
anything illegal taking place there we
went in on a supervised visit it you
know it's very difficult for us to get
under the skin of what happened in the
way that undercover journalists and so
on so one can I think this needs to be
much more transparency I think more
people including the media ought to be
allowed regular access to these women
they're not getting proper access to
decent legal advice and that's a massive
problem so I think I think the policy
stinks and the and the establishment
probably needs to be closed down in due
course on brexit once again we see
labour edging closer to a very explicit
position big speech from your leader
tomorrow what's it going to see a
customs union the customer how do you
talk about a seismic shift which
obviously is your job because you want
people to wake up on a Sunday morning
and not not turn optically after the
rugby result yesterday yes absolutely I
don't think you're gonna get a seismic
shift I don't feel that we're in a very
different place from when I last
discussed brexit with you but what we
are going to get is more flesh on the
bones as you would expect and this at
this point in the process from you know
a prime minister in Waiting we have said
that we honor the the referendum result
even those of us who are passionate
remain as and campaigned in the other
direction but there is democracy
tradition there is a result a customs
union the customs new years perhaps
something of a distraction anything
given that it's just whether you sign it
bilaterally or whether you sign under
the European Union framework however
people I thought a customs union would
be a death disaster that's what the
shadow brexit secretary said to me
sitting in that very chair
he said that we would be a vassal state
of the European Union it actually sounds
quite recent market well that's that
that's the the customs union rather than
that that's a question about and making
sure that you have some say about what
the standards are and on what rules
you're living under and that's a matter
for negotiation because you clearly
don't want to be the vassal state etc
etc but it's incredibly important that
we have a decent deal and a close
partnership with our nearest neighbors
we also don't want a hard border on the
island of Ireland and that's something
that we take incredibly seriously in
labor party because the Good Friday
Agreement was an incredibly important
achievement you also want is the ability
to sign free trade agreements outside of
your relationship with the European
Union
what happens if well this is a matter
for this is all a matter for negotiation
we know what our values are but I have
been in the room with Jeremy Corbyn when
senior Europeans have been in that room
and all I can tell you is that those
were very friendly rooms because they
trust us they trust our values on
environmental protection workers
protection human rights protection and
they know well that's a matter fit you
know that's a question of negotiation
all I'm saying is that I have no doubt
in my mind that it would be much easier
for us to negotiate a decent deal with
our European friends and it is for the
Conservatives whether the fairly brittle
and at times toxic relationship in their
negotiations the reason I ask the
questions I'm wondering what the
priority would be whether it is the
customs union a customs union with the
European Union or whether it is the
ability to be able to sign free-trade
agreements and if they say no if it
currently included in the bilateral
agreement for a costumes union would you
rather be in the customs union without
that ability or would you rather be
outside of it you know what I'm going to
say the priority is the economy and and
there's jobs for people and I'm not
going to get into hypotheticals about
people saying no to XY and said I think
that that is a mistake but the
difference between us and the
Conservatives and it is really a
difference of values about the kind of
country that we want to be going forward
I would have thought that the Archbishop
of Canterbury for example will be
welcoming Jeremy Corbyn speech tomorrow
because he shares our concern about this
very unequal very divided Britain but
whether we're the most vulnerable are
crushed by austerity I thought that you
know protecting jobs and respecting the
result of the referendum I mean they're
entirely contradictory only not
necessarily not necessarily it's it's
not everything isn't about whether
you're in or out of the European Union
the question now is what kind of
relationship you have with your closest
neighbors and what kind of a Britain you
want to build post brexit and that I
think is what jeremy corbyn's going to
talk about tomorrow and our vision is it
is a world away from that of
but the of the Tory Party at Civil War
in what way is it respecting the result
of the referendum to enter into our
customs union whereby we restrict our
ability to do deals with the rest of the
world well let let's see what that looks
like that it's the great betrayal
argument again that you're not listening
to your heartlines you're not listening
to the we absolutely are because we are
we are leaving and we absolutely are
because before exams it believing if you
can't sign free-trade agreements with
the rest of the world that's what I
think people in our heartlands are
really worried about it is for example
the posting of work forces to undercut
to undercut their terms and conditions
in their wages well I think people in
our heartlands are desperately worried
about our housing and homelessness and
austerity and that's where the brexit
but-but-but-but brexit becomes an
existential issue until you start
talking about what it means for people
which is they want jobs they want they
want to benefit from economic prosperity
and not see it only benefiting a very
small and minority of people in this
country and what jeremy will do tomorrow
is make this relationship between all
the noise about brexit and and what
really concerns people in their daily
lives
what's all wrong with the single market
I mean just as Jeremy Corbyn is putting
the finishing touches to tomorrow's
speech we've got Labour MPs and peas
your peers trade unionists all
suggesting and that we should remain in
the single market what's wrong with it
well we can't remain in the it's back to
your semantics we're not going to remain
in the single market we're not going to
be members of the European Union but we
want the closest possible relationship
with our neighbors whether it's on
matters of trade and we want access to
that market it's incredibly important
for us after our European partners but
also we want cooperation on security on
medicines control on food standards and
so on and you know what I believe that
most European leaders trust us when we
say that and it's a very very different
set of values from the Conservatives
we've often heard in in recent weeks and
months that there's no place for pur
anti-semitism in the labour party is
there a place for Ken Livingstone well
obviously I'm not judge and jury in
relation to Ken Livingstone or anyone
else he has been suspended from the
party for some time but but equally
people report that he has said things
and done things since that suspension so
that is something that the the National
Executive Committee of our party is
going to have to look at well isn't the
Oh on that point I mean isn't it the
case that no one has been judge and jury
in the case of Ken Livingstone the
enquiry
you know unknowns by Jeremy Corbyn some
ten months ago hasn't even started well
no I mean as I say about Labor Party's
commitment to dealing with anti-semitism
ken is currently suspended from the
party in relation to findings against
him and it's clear to me that before any
prospect of him being allowed back into
the party subsequent matters need to be
looked at that is just due process that
is due process and that's what I think
we should we should follow okay do you
think that Hitler was a Zionist I mean
do you know I just hope that you
understand just how insulting it was
then Livingstone on Iranian television
of all things on Holocaust Memorial Day
making those comments
I completely condemn those comments I
completely condemned those comments and
that they should be properly adjudicated
on by the National Executive it I did a
bit like you were being judging Julie
there well have my opinion but but other
people have their opinions and he is
entitled to due process that is that is
very important when you're dealing with
bad behavior in any institution or
political party do you accept that you
report into anti-semitism within the
Labour Party maybe for you in a nobleman
of course was considered a whitewash by
many Jewish members of the party
I know what people have said but there
are other people who who said they'd
like to see that report fully
implemented and that and that's really
what I'm working towards now what we've
always seen is a change in standards
we've seen a more explicit change in
standards so that certain phrases and
certain ways of talking about your
fellow fellow party members are now
clearly ruled out in the party that's
clear but what we need to do more of is
to deal with this due process point
that's not just being fair to the person
accused
that's being fair to the people who've
been abused and making sure as you've
indicated that they get earlier due
process
and we learned this week that a change
is coming for the ownership of the Free
Press in this country that mr. Corbyn
wants a an end to a handful of tax
dodging you know foreign billionaires
controlling the majority of newsprint
given that the the key principle of a
free press is that it is free from state
interference yeah how does he how is he
going to do that there's no question of
state interference I know that's I know
that some newspapers have been worried
about that and suggested that this
change is coming it is a threat it it's
not a threat it's how is he going to do
it well the change is already coming
because we the people are getting our
news from a range of sources but the
change that is becoming in relation to
billionaire tax exile so applies to
people whether they're press barons or
running other big companies there is no
attack on the I've defended the Free
Press all my adult life did you have not
going to change that position now so
when he finalized those plans for
dealing with pesky phone and
billionaires where will he announced it
I'm not sure today or in PressTV
possibly via his own Twitter feed
because that is the nature of modern
media now I American on social media
networks well I mean that brings it so I
mean that that brings its own challenges
however I mean you know social media is
has it has a wonderful democratizing
possibility look at storm Z and the way
that he managed to mobilize all those
people to express their concerns about
Grenville there's a dark side to and and
that's something that we we often have
to deal with but I think the change is
coming the change to some extent has
already come and that's a good thing and
that should make it less possible for
people to spread the lies and smears and
fake news including about Jeremy Corbyn